منذ ان ضرب الزلزال بيوتها تفترش هذه
العائلات الارض وتلتحف السماء
همهم الوحيد تامين خيمه وبعض الاغطيه
تقيهم البرد القارص درجات حراره تنخفض الى
ما دون صفر
خرجت ام محمد مع ابنائها واحفادها سالمين
من الزلزال
ومطالبها ليست كثيره
ندرك تحتها ما في بالشمس عم ندبر حالنا بس
بالليل نحن ما في عنا شيء ما عنا
مشققه والتحذيرات على الهواتف اني لا حدا
يفوت على دور المشققه وهيك
عشرات الاطفال انتشلوا من تحت انقاض
منازلهم في ادلب الشمالي يحتاجون الى
الدفئ والرعايه الطبيه والنفسيه
تزال شمال غربي سوريا ينتظرون وصول
مساعدات عاجله تخفف عنهم تداعيات زلزال قد
تطول في منطقه تعاني اصلا من الفقر وندره
المساعدات
مساعدات امميه وصفت بالمتاخره والخجوله
دخلت من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا
وهي بحسب القائمين على المعبر ضمن اطار
برنامج الدعم الاعتيادي للنازحين اما فيما
يتعلق بالاستجابه الطارئه للزلزال فلن
تدخل اي معدات ثقيله تساعد في عمليات
البحث والانقاذ ولا اي المساعدات طبيه
دخلت قبل قليل قافله قادم من الامم
المتحده مكونه من اربعه عشر شاحنه محمله
بمختلف المواد الاغاثيه لغاثه اثناء
المنكوبين جراء هذا الزلزال فيها مستلزمات
للقيام بطانيات واسفنجات وعوازل بالاضافه
لبعض صله للنظافه وبعض السلا الغذائيه
وحدها جثث الضحايا السوريين الذين قضوا في
زلزال كهرمان مارش كانت اسرع بالدخول الى
سوريا من فرق الانقاذ والمساعدات الطبيه
اكثر من 600 ضحيه دخلت من تركيا الى
الشمال السوري هم اللاجئون فرو من الموت
في سوريا
ليلقوه هناك ويعود دون تاشيره او جواز سفر
ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره الشمالي